one of the odd things Sherlock fans do
is when Benedict was here he was telling
us about how they compared him to an
otter and and you it seems unlikely but
here's a classic of the Bears better to
come back and here he is looking like an
officer look yeah so now they thought
they've got you compared to another
woodland creature hmm
Jun do you know what's coming no I know
you don't follow me on the Internet
can you guess what woodland creature
martin freeman might be careful other
sides ah keep it clean it's really
unlikely cat weasel unbelievable evilly
reach
in the one
no it is it's a hedgehog no and you kind
of think I opened a personal baguette or
because a hedgehog is not expressive
wrong I'm so wrong so here's his Martin
there's Martin and you got to make a
head child couldn't and head up like
that I just couldn't look like that
happy Hedgehog then we've got a less
happy Martin does he have a hedgehog to
look like him yes I don't think it looks
like a hedgehog at all I think that just
anybody making a face you put a hedgehog
next doesn't look like a hedgehog I
think I think been seen through the
Florence okay explain this one then this
is so specific okay okay now look at the
Hedgehog who started it I rest my case
your honor
yeah okay this is it this is okay if you
don't find it this is the clincher okay
okay here's Martin Friedman obviously
encountering fans and
how could a hedgehog do this not
possible I'm told this isn't
photoshopped also looks like a mutant
Hedgehog
but I was in one with Kiefer Sutherland
it was funny and he came out he said my
head man he said I haven't screamed so
much since I was married with the
leaning
yeah I was really good lucky she was
there Dallas buyers club wait you would
have flattened her